this strain of coronavirus is related to
the common cold as well as the more
serious and highly infectious SARS or
severe acute respiratory syndrome at the
moment there is no vaccine or known cure
for this new virus what we do know is
that it most likely passed from animals
to humans in a market in the Chinese
city of Wuhan and it's believed to have
likely originated in bats Chinese
scientists were able to quickly identify
its genetic sequence allowing
researchers across the world to start
work on treatments in Australia
officials say they've developed
lab-grown version of the virus which
would be a major step towards creating a
vaccine drugs used to fight HIV and
influenza have been tested in China as
possible treatments and officials say
they are showing promising science
however the World Health Organization
has played down reports of any kind of
breakthrough but some drug makers are
expected to begin vaccine tests on
humans possibly within 3 months that may
seem a while away but this process has
traditionally taken years right now some
of the best ways to prevent the spread
of corona virus is to avoid contact with
those showing symptoms washing your
hands regularly and covering your mouth
when coughing or sneezing